beißen
der hund beißt den mann
der hund hat den mann gebissen
[Musik]
sitzen sie sitzt auf dem stuhl
sie ist auf dem stuhl gesessen
sie hat auf dem stuhl gesessen
untersuchen
er untersucht den patienten
er hat den patienten untersucht
reiten
er reitet auf dem pferd er ist auf dem
pferd geritten sprechen
[Musik]
der moderator spricht mit den politikern
er hat mit den politikern gesprochen
sprechen sie spricht deutsch
sie hat deutsch gesprochen
reiten er reitet auf dem pferd er ist
auf dem pferd geritten untersuchen
die ärztin untersucht den patienten
sie hat den patienten untersucht sitzen
er sitzt auf dem stuhl er ist auf dem
stuhl gesessen er hat auf dem stuhl
gesessen beißen
der hund beißt den pöstler er hat den
pöstler gebissen